okay why don't we why don't we go ahead
and get started
this is this is a packed room I don't
know that there are any open seats that
well because actually because of
actually Connors doing work in the EPC
and being a B C D student we kind of
have the whole departments span yeah so
this is great but I always like to see
this I wouldn't mind seeing this every
every conference just to let people know
so anyways today's sessions we we always
do at least one of these because we
always have people who are presenting at
the AMIA meeting the American Medical
Informatics Association meeting which
festivities started on Saturday and
actually go through Wednesday we always
have a big presence there it's an
important meeting actually as I was
telling a couple of our clinical
informatics fellows last week this is my
this will be my thirty third consecutive
meeting Amy and meeting dating back to
1986 which two of them informed me that
that was the year they were born so
which I proceeded to tweet that and my
daughter who some of you know who's a
medical student said that was five years
before I was born so anyways I guess
I've been around a while and you know
but the Amy a meeting is always a big
event actually one thing some of you if
you follow our twitter feed know that
the there was just the inaugural class
of fellows of a Mia people who have been
around in contributing and informatics
into a Mia and 130 people were will be
in the inaugural class and they posted
the list and it turns out that 15 people
on that list are alumni of our program
so more than 10 percent of the fellows
of Amy
our alumni of Hsu and they're all over
the place so we were really pleased with
that and I'm sure we'll we'll keep those
numbers up because there's many more
people who are eligible and hopefully
they will achieve that status next year
so anyways the purpose of this session
these talks is to give people a chance
to practice in front of an audience that
they will be presenting in San Francisco
this weekend or next week and just it's
it's always helpful even for those of us
who have been doing this for many many
years it's still useful to to do these
practice talks and then also to give
some of you who might not be attending
the opportunity there the talks I know
that were I would get started in a
moment I promise I know that we're
competing with the presidents our new
president Danny Jacobs at noon I'm told
that that will be recorded so you don't
really need to leave although if you
really want to you can we'll understand
but that will be recorded and available
so people can whenever it's posted on
the internet you'll be able to to view
it ok so so we have two talks today one
is who most of you know one of our
esteemed faculty dr. Joe Nash who will
be presenting her work and then we also
I'll talk a little bit about it but
Connor Smith when is presenting in the
Aeneid design challenge I'll talk about
that a little bit before he presents
because there's a another great Hsu
story behind that
so thanks Bill is this on yes good all
right so this is supposed to be a
15-minute talk it's a podium
presentation meaning that I submitted an
abstract many many months ago it was
accepted and I get to present it but
it's not a published paper so we get to
actually
publish something after this these are
the co-authors for the presentation I
like to thank them and also arc for the
funding Jeff Gould is the principal
investigator on this particular arc
grant and our other team members who
will be on the final paper who have
contributed a lot since we wrote the
abstract so Thomas and Chris Ben and
Nick sobered so the title was about
scribes but first we need to define
scratch because it's not really very
clear what they are according to the
experts their documentation assistance
so that they assist providers like this
one in the picture in doing their
documentation and they really come along
since EHRs came along there is no
specific licensure for scribes yet
because it's a fairly new industry CMS
AHIMA the Joint Commission have
published some guidance but it's not all
that helpful there are no regulations
about it and so part of the problem is
this is an unregulated industry however
it's been shown to be a good industry in
that a really good study that just came
out in JAMA internal medicine the best
probably that's been published so far
about scribes indicates that providers
love it it helps them with their
efficiency it lessens burnout
patients love it scribes love it because
they get jobs but they get paid for it
the problem is that it is such a
fast-growing industry it's not regulated
and estimates are there are 20,000
scribes in the US right now and there
will be a hundred thousand by 2020 so
when we say fast-growing it really is
fast growing so a commentary paper in
that same issue of JAMA internal
medicine by our colleague Dave Bates and
Adam Landon
actually says well yes they're all
good things about scribes but on the
other hand they're an unintended
consequence of the EHRs and it's
probably a short-term workaround so that
we're especially in informatics working
on other solutions to this documentation
problem but the big problem is that
documentation is just an extra burden on
providers so our purpose was to describe
activities of medical scribes using the
EHR and identify best practices across
multiple types of organizations no one
has really sort of identified the
industry or the career yet for the
ultimate goal after five years is to
provide training models for scribes and
arc will make those available so we use
this really simplistic there are many
socio-technical model diagrams out there
but we use this very simplistic one so
that pretty much everything having to do
with informatics and the EHR you can put
into these different perspectives
personal environmental technical or
organizational and so we just use this
as a framework for looking at scribes we
used our rapid ethnographic process for
doing this so that it's team-based it's
a way of gathering and analyzing and
doing things fairly quickly it's a menu
of qualitative and quantitative methods
for this we use qualitative primarily
interviews and observations and then we
used a grounded hermeneutic approach to
analysis which just means an inductive
approach so we gathered a lot of data we
did actually this we've done a thorough
analysis of site a and site D we've done
a lightweight analysis of site
C and we just finished site the last
week so we haven't included that in this
analysis yet so these results are
preliminary but even up to this point we
had done interviews with 50 different
individuals we had done observations in
six clinics and then quite a few hours
of observation in those clinics I should
also say that the different models
subscribing used at these places were
and in
Colonel program at an academic
institution a company provided group of
scribes at another community
organization and then an antique clinic
where they use a virtual remote model I
guess you would call it
so looking at those different
perspectives after our analysis we came
up with 10 themes which fall nicely into
the four areas but I'm just going to
talk about those in red because I only
have a total of 15 minutes but basically
we had different perspectives of scribes
and providers and others like
administrators another theme of course
was training because that's our ultimate
goal we're finding describe provider
interaction is a really really
interesting area for the environmental
side the whole scribe industry is very
interesting but I'm going to focus more
on the compliance and safety issues from
a technical perspective both the EHR and
ergonomics surrounding the EHR have come
up as themes and then from an
organizational perspective of course
efficiency the quality of documentation
and the coding for billing and then
these differing scribe models and
variability within them so for the
personal perspective from the providers
perspective this is what they look like
when we go out there and we observe they
are so happy to have scribes there their
scribe Envy very often when people don't
have scribes or other providers yet
scribes so they think being able to go
home on time is a really good thing
absolutely but the challenges are that
at least for the pre-professional model
of scribes where these are either
college students or graduates who are
trying to get into medical school or PA
school pre-professional of course they
only stay 12 months to 18 months and so
the providers have this burden of
constantly adding to their training even
if a company or a program gives them
training the providers have to give them
individual training about the
they do things the providers need
training also we're finding so we our
whole grant was about training scribes
but we're now thinking that we need to
do some provider training as well
because some providers use scribes
better than other providers the one
thing that providers told us was a big
downside as they become too dependent on
the scribes and we might say well there
are risks involved in that too and that
may be that providers aren't learning
how to use the EHR at one of our places
that was definitely the case from the
scribe point of view for the pre
professionals it picks starts their
careers they get a letter of reference
they have all this great background
before they apply to the professional
school they actually get paid for
something in old days they volunteered
to do it maybe minimum wage but they do
get paid something they're making a
contribution and they're constantly
learning while the scribes on the other
side often they're paid minimum wage
there's a steep learning curve
especially since many of them start out
in the emergency department where
everything comes in and you know
sometimes the interactions with
providers are not always super positive
now some of the scribes may have held
back in that they're actually working
for the organization's now and and some
of the companies have non-disclosure
agreements but the scribes I think
pretty much told us a straight scoop
from the patient point of view we did
talk to patients but both the providers
and the scribes and others told us that
patients rarely object we did find
though that they must be introduced
properly they should have the provider
money you know really should say this is
my scribe this is my scribe to name and
why I described it in the room because
otherwise the patient's can be really
puzzled and patients often having a
third person in the room they need to
know who got third personnel and then
this whole idea of the interaction the
upsides are that if they work together
if a dyad scribe provider diet worked
really well together they can become
incredibly efficient and they build
relationships with one another the sky's
like to be taught providers like to
teach the challenges though are that
constantly recruiting scribes every 12
months to replace the scribe you know
obviously puts Human Resources
challenges in the way also matching the
right provider to the right scribe is a
challenge and the providers have to
accept a lot of responsibility they may
not realize ahead of time they need to
communicate well with the scribe provide
feedback do evaluations and really
carefully review the documentation it's
up to them you know there are the ones
responsible for it and we found that
they don't if they really trust their
scribe they tend not to check things
over as well as they possibly should
from the environmental perspective there
is this guidance available but in the
larger sites and the companies seem to
be aware of it and they try to provide
boundaries around what a scribe can do
they're not licensed and therefore they
should not be doing anything with
patients they should not be hands-on
with patients at all that's a pretty
strict boundary that we found broken
fairly often it's after all the scribes
want to learn more and the providers
want them to do more and so together
they're constantly pushing the
boundaries and at the smaller sites
where there's not as much oversight they
may go beyond the boundaries so that
this is a bit of a risk to the patients
and liability for the organization and
the EHR point of view the upsides are
that the scribes are really good at
using the EHR and in fact sometimes
they're the real go-to people for the
providers and enable standardization of
care because the scribe and provider can
gris on templates and dot phrases and
that kind of thing which really helps
efficiency the EHR helps them with that
efficiency but as you know it takes an
investment of time to develop those
efficiencies and
templates as usual upgrades cause
problems and the scribes maybe the
scribes don't necessarily work for the
organization they might work for a
scribe company and so sometimes they're
a little bit left out of the
organizational communication about
what's going on with the EHR and
ergonomics are such a huge challenge I
mean this is typical but we've also seen
the scribes in a very small place with
their laptops on their knees balanced on
their knees typing with one hand sitting
on sinks sitting anywhere they can and
the rooms haven't been designed for that
extra person in the room the industry's
only been around for a few years but
that's what I mean by agile the models
of describing different models of
scribing there were so many models
sometimes it's hard for organizations to
choose from the pre-professional model
really motivated really bright people
but they don't stay long the
professional model where they do stay
they are more stable within an
organization but they may not have that
motivation the clinical model is when
you use mas nurses or others to
describing but they have to have a clear
differentiation they have to put on
their scribe hat when they do
documentation because it's hard to do
your ma thing and your scribing thing at
the same time and there are issues of
safety with that company versus internal
the companies do the HR part of it which
sometimes can be too much of a burden
for the organization but then again the
organization has to pay more for that
and this whole future of virtual or a I
assisted scribing is definitely coming
down the pike it may take over
inscribing industry but not tomorrow but
it's an interesting model and people are
playing with it so each model has its
strengths and weaknesses so there are
upsides to using scribes everybody says
so the downsides are there are these
risks
and what we've learned so far is that
it's not all on the backs of this
scribes but the training also has to
include the providers so that you can
have this very positive interaction
that's also producing efficiencies
between these dyads of scribes and
providers doctors save lives providers
say well I described save doctors so
thank you how did I'll still have to cut
it down because they only give us a
total of 18 minutes so 15 for their talk
and three for questions and answers and
I probably talk too fast just squeeze it
all in so I'll have to cut something out
it's interesting that you know some
people say in fact I think David Bates
says this that that scribes are in
essence a symptom of how poorly we've
designed our EHRs and how difficult they
are to use but you said that it's
estimated that the marketplace is going
to increase so do people think that our
user interfaces are going to continue to
be bad and have a continued expansion of
scribes great question and in fact
they're there a couple of papers written
by Deloitte in Texas someone I don't
know but he's a very strong opinionated
writer author and he claims that by
using scribes were undermining the
further development of EHRs that we're
stifling development at EHRs because the
providers aren't getting after the
vendors to make them better because they
have this stopgap measure in place and
Dave Bates
I know feel somewhat the same way you
know he feels documentation processing
have to be different in the United
States he you know has published a study
showing that documentation in the US is
four times longer than elsewhere in the
world so we are definitely overburdened
with documentation but the other point
in this commentary paper was that
usability is so bad that until we do
something about that or the vendors do
something about that
we're gonna need scribes follow up on
that one
high productivity settings right such
that basically metaphor so this
mr. Geller opinion that we're still
going to continue to have for a long
time like to have scribes but but do not
well that's the scribe Envy part but the
places we've been they do seem to feel
that there's a return on investment for
scribes and minimum wage is actually
pretty cheap usually providers have to
promise to see more patients every day
one place they had to promise to see one
patient extra a day another place three
extra patients a day and that's where
the return on investment comes in
because they really do make new more
efficient no matter what your specialty
errand
calling scribes an unintended
consequence of the designer reads EHRs
is you know very judgmental right and
implies a whole bunch of assumptions
that I'm not sure are tested or are true
such as even with the greatest
documentation system with the most
usability that it's really the best use
of the providers time to be documenting
and feeding that into the EHR I don't
know if that's true or not so I guess
the question that I have is in your
discussions did you hear anything that
thought that there was a real problem
with having scribes because almost
everything that you said you know scribe
envy and higher you know throughput and
that provides so you're what I'm hearing
from you is that the providers are happy
to have take on the responsibility of
seeing an extra patient today so they
can have a scribe so if everybody's
happy and more people are getting taken
care of and the documentation is at
least as good as it needs to be what's
the problem even if we didn't think of
it in advance and it winds up being a
quote unquote unintended consequence
well people still worry that having a
third person in the room might make
patients nervous you know we talked to
people who say the press Gainey's and
I'll pretty much say that the patients
are fine with this but there are times
when they don't want that person in the
room so that has to be handled really
well any team members hear about the
downsides of having scribes will cost us
one
I I think that's a worry I think that's
a worry Chris did you have
and then an alert fire there has to be
some sort of a process to get that alert
to the mind of the physician some take
care of it some do the orders after but
if they really are uber efficient
sometimes that's assumed and you do some
of that functionality and if many places
the scribes are allowed to pan the
orders and so they're actually kind of
doing orders and so I think it is a risk
that there are compliance and risk
issues in that something could go wrong
in that the provider who's responsible
may not be reviewing those pending
orders very carefully there's also a
concern about the documentation itself
and having to correct it and if a
provider is having to spend another
extra time going over that documentation
then there may not be that much time
saving so well actually this this last
study by Mishra and Christine Sinskey
study have shown that there really are
amazing time savings and where a
provider might have spent four hours
documenting after work it's it's down to
a few minutes now so you said there's I
think that the two of them are part of
one presentation okay so we actually
have that we have time for questions
great talk I'm sorry if this question
sort of is coming out of left field but
I'm curious to know if you know the
literature on what is the actual role of
either electronic or written
documentation and like the providers
ability to like deliver good care like
is there an actual role for like writing
it down yourself or entering into the
EHR and
has anyone tried to study that in somes
not that I know of except that we have
been told by providers when we interview
them that sometimes they they miss that
cognitive length between writing it down
and they're more prone to forget yeah I
mean I imagine it's a wide distribution
right like before the age of EHRs like
some providers I'm sure like we're
really meticulous and spent a lot of
time writing sometime because that's how
they could remember it versus others
like relied on other sort of like you
know mental shortcuts to stay up on
their patients but it would just be
interesting to know and that would be a
great study I think the biggest been
trying to ask the question for a while I
was like going on foot what bill said
earlier is there been any work on kind
of proto scribes or people who performed
a role similar to what the modern scribe
does before electronic EHRs so but it
seems that a lot of the work the scribe
is doing is not just taking the work off
of the handling a click the interface
but just writing stuff down in any
context is at roar and takes time so was
it just that physicians were going
through writing things out by hand when
they did and then the extra inefficiency
is the HR was just too much and that
broken that's why one describes or were
there people who were performing similar
roles in terms of typing out the
physicians note after a visit or office
secretaries or someone in the old days
that might have been doing something
more similar to what the scribes are
they're offloading some of that
administrative work before we had our
current system new providers in the room
correct me if I'm wrong but I think in
the old days there was just a lot less
documentation and more to the point
shorter not all the requirements from
the environmental pressures to do
documentation so there was just a lot
less and the EHR in my theory has
enabled all of this extra doc
vacation to come along so I'm gonna have
to well I I don't really want to cut
everyone off but but exercise do you
want to give enough time then and
additional questions so Joan is always
around so if you want to talk further
with her and there are team members
around all the time - yes good ok so I
our second presentation actually two
presenters I didn't know that
and so Connor and Becky are finalists in
the amias student design challenge which
is it's a different design change it's
the Ritz not the student design you know
not students okay is it focused in a
certain area yes it's part of the ninth
annual okay well but we I think we do
have a finalists and the student design
challenge as well which I was just gonna
say because you know how I like to brag
about you guys that the first three
years of the amias student design
challenge the three winning teams were
from OHSU and now there's another group
that is a finalist this year they're
presenting their poster I think on
Sunday and hopefully they'll do well
okay well and so maybe xD Connor and
Becky can before they start maybe tell
us a little bit about the event what's
now that you mentioned and I remember
reading about but i sorry i completed
the two and and then so you're you get
fifteen minutes to talk so well time you
and now
give you a two-minute warning as often
people do at the meeting and it's always
really important especially for those of
you who are not familiar with doing this
that if they give you 15 minutes to talk
that you'd be certain that you finished
your talking within 15 minutes
especially actually in our contest okay
so why don't you go ahead and let me
know when you're starting your actual
talk and then I'll start okay so yeah we
entered into a to kind of give some
background on this we were working on an
EPC project a pilot project for art
regarding visualization our alternative
methods for disseminating systematic
reviews so we were working on that and
then Shannon actually sent out an email
about a call for papers and it sounded
like a good fit so it's the 9th annual
workshop in visual analytics and
healthcare it's a workshop that's split
between the yearly split between I
Triple E and a Mia so it jumps in
between those and this is their first
year of doing a design challenge and so
we are competing with five other teams
and the top three will get published in
a special topics in visual analytics yes
and two hundred dollar gift cards so so
yeah I'm actually gonna thanks and we
actually have not gone through this at
all even between ourselves so this this
is before we commit them a script to
memory we wanted to kind of tell the
story first just to see if it makes
sense if it's coherent if it's
interesting and then we'll actually
practice so oh right so and the point of
me being up here is to introduce the
systematic reviews and the research
because there's any to an audience that
I think isn't going to have a lot of
background of that and then we're gonna
turn it over to Conor and so I hope that
the story is coherent but I think the
feedback that I would appreciate most is
on the actual design
fortunately but it's so many of us are
engaged in new research on an ongoing
basis but what is the actual purpose of
that research and it's really to create
it you know it's so when we're
conducting research we're taking
evidence we're taking observations and
we're contributing to our shared
knowledge base in the particular health
field and a medical research our
long-term goal is typically to inform
providers decision making so they can
deliver evidence-based effective quality
care for their patients but our
contributions of research aren't
magically integrated into practice do we
have to scrutinize to to vet them and
really come to a consensus to make sure
that we're doing what's best for the
patient and once a strong body of
evidence has been established then we
can consider translating some of this
research into actual practice and often
in the Health System the incorporation
of that takes the form of practice
guidelines so a major component of
guideline development is actually a
systematic review so a systematic review
is different from just a regular
traditional review article in that you
have the scientific approach to
collecting information and synthesizing
the information to answer specific
questions so the research questions are
structured
they're peer-reviewed and you have to
follow and explicit and pre-specified
protocol so researching or summarizing
they're synthesizing the data they're
evaluating the quality of the individual
studies as well as the body of evidence
as a whole and these reviews are really
complicated they depend largely on
what's even out there in the in the body
of literature the quality of the studies
as well as how are you defining the
health comes that you're going to be
measuring so along with these giant
systematic reviews as well as some
pragmatic experience based on the
clinicians you form and develop
guidelines for clinical practice what
led to this particular project so
currently systematic reviews they're
presented as these enormous static PDF
documents online they're filled with
tons of tables charts for example so our
Pacific Northwest evidence
practice centre EPC we completed a
systematic review of non-invasive
nonpharmacologic treatments for chronic
pain the report was funded by the agency
for Healthcare Research and quality art
and it's available for download if you
have a whole lot of time the so the full
document itself
the reason we're putting this out is the
full document was one thousand three
hundred ninety eight pages
so three hundred plus of those were the
main body you had over a thousand pages
in the appendix there was let's see
within there we had a 25 page executive
summary which isn't exactly a summary
sixty two tables fifty two figures and
all of these data came from two hundred
and two studies so the point is to say
that's a lot of material that's a lot of
material for anybody let alone you know
a panel of really busy physicians
clinicians trying to read and digest
some important information before making
guidelines that are gonna guide how they
practice so what are some of the
challenges you've got this massive
report a lot of information a lot of
really good evidence but it's really a
lot to internalize so we're pretty good
at taking the evidencing thing you know
let's chunk this out and make this
chapter this chapter and then make
decisions based on that but this becomes
a problem when you increase the
dimensionality of a report so for
example just in this tiny little report
we had five different types of pain
there were eight different interventions
and we have a look at these across six
different outcomes so it's pretty
difficult to look at a systematic review
already but when you increase it by all
of these different dimensions it's even
more difficult in addition you've got
this rigid structure so PDFs you can't
do a lot with you can maybe print out
all the tables and cut and paste and
arrange them how you want but you're not
gonna get a lot of good information and
quickly that way so the problem there is
if you if your question is what exactly
what the research questions were in the
systematic review great you have your
answers but if you're looking at
something a little bit different then
you're gonna have a lot of trouble
finding the information that
so so to take a look at this arc asked
us to the very cpc's across the country
to look for potential methods for
presenting the data from systematic
reviews that would make these reports
more accessible and more usable the
problem is definitely in the realm of
informatics in that it sorry the problem
is definitely in the realm of
informatics but unfortunately most UPC's
don't include informatics person on
their staff
luckily the Pacific Northwest EPC is
pretty well integrated with de maiz here
and so we kind of have folk kind of an
advantage at that point so this is
essentially how we got integrated so we
wanted to engage EPCs to develop and
pilot test potential tools to enhance
the evidence uptake from there what we
did is we use the as mentioned before
they published a report on chronic pain
and before we started we kind of wanted
to establish some selection criteria for
whatever tool we would be using as I
mentioned before not a lot of EP C's
have informatics professionals so
building something in our pipeline might
not be exactly useable across the board
so instead what we want to look is for
an existing off-the-shelf product that
had no or minimal need for informatics
for formal informatics training we
wanted to in especially one that had a
robust customer support department
oh he's in mind we ended up selecting
tableau and one of the reasons why not -
is that tableau is already pretty well
integrated into many health systems
across the board so it just kind of it
worked out well so from here I since it
is a design challenge we wanted to look
at a demo of this we essentially for
this we kind of modelled the report
after the standard in systematic reviews
which is a forest plot it's not exactly
the same but you'll be able to tell if
you've ever seen one before
so this is published on a tableau public
currently and it's out there so you can
take a look at it it's a lot going on
and I know the text is very small on
this projector but essentially the way
that it works is that it's splitting the
a couple different sections at the top
you can see that there are some filters
that you can use to kind of break down
those dimensions that we talked about
earlier different types of intervention
the outcomes you're working on paint
versus function and the different
conditions from there in this top
section you have the summary which is
going to be these aggregate measures of
the studies that they found below you're
going to have the actual studies and
details about those now the main
function of this is so that if you
wanted to look at say chronic low back
pain with X's you're looking at exercise
as an intervention compared to the usual
care they want to look at the effect on
function we can kind of subset these and
it's going to provide a little bit more
detail for us down here so now we're
only looking at these and down here you
can see what makes up those aggregations
there's additional info within these
boxes when you hover over it tells you
about the strength of evidence the
number of studies number of patients all
those kind of things
excuse me all those kind of things so in
addition to this we also created a
guided comparison which is a nice way to
kind of show how someone would use this
without being at a talk about how to use
it so at the topic just put in some
texts talking about this tool is
designed to allow you to look across
different look across the data in
different ways that the report isn't
designed to the original report isn't
designed in a way for you to do that for
example working across these different
interventions and kind of seeing how
they work how they are comparatively so
for this we decided to let's look at
exercise and the effect it has on pain
you're gonna see it across different
types of pain all down here and all the
different studies involved with that but
say we want to look more at the
short-term effect on chronic low back
pain
so we zoom in on that if we hover over
this we can look at that summary
information
we can see that there was 553 patients
across six studies the strength of
evidence is moderate and then if we want
to look even further we can look at a
specific study down here we can get a
lot of information about it we can get
the actual patient information the
number of patients in each group to
control an intervention and if we want
to we can even go north of the abstract
PubMed so those are the the main parts
of the report that we designed just so
that we could get a better just an
alternate method for looking at this
data so some caveats and limitations
we'll say this is definitely a
supplement to the original report is not
meant to replace there's just so much
information in those thousands of pages
that you can't exactly get across in
something like this another part is that
this is really a quantitatively focused
method for presenting the data so we
haven't really met we haven't tried
playing around with any qualitatively
focus but I'm sure someone can figure
out a way last week even though this
report is going to be more dynamic than
the original one it's still going to be
pretty it's still gonna be tethered to
how you structure your data how you
collect your data how you store it how
you aggregate it all of that is going to
define what eventually comes out in your
your visualization for us one thing is
we had to actually extract all of the
data out of the PDF report by hand so
that took some time but that kind of
shows that if it's not stored properly
you're gonna have a hard time dealing
with that so we just so from there
that's this is what we've come up with
at this point we believe that the
project kind of shows an importance of
any potential benefit of integrating
informatics into this kind of work you
believe that this kind of a report can
help improve dissemination of the data
and increase accessibility and find new
ways to present on top of that we do
think that more research we need to
we need to look at more ways to further
increase the accessibility and different
ways to present the data our setup is
kind of limited to a very dense a very
dense data visualization so it can be
kind of tough on smaller screens so we
imagine that there could be a lot of
different ways to present this as well
and that's it well the good news is that
you've about you have almost four
minutes extra time which and actually
well I don't know if they give any
guidelines on what you're supposed to
talk about because I can think of a
couple areas that I probably moat
probably most informatics people like me
it would be interested in knowing more
about but did they give you any
guidelines on what you're supposed okay
we definitely thought the biggest part
was kind of communicating why you know
the why of why we care kind of thing and
kind of telling the story of how we got
to where we are with this I do know for
the final presentations they've it's
pretty rigid at least in the schedule
they've given each group only has 15
minutes and I think so that means
anything happening in that 15 minutes is
Orkut okay I don't think there is any
discussion it's you just get 15 minutes
and then later in the afternoon they do
the judging in what and what they won't
they won't have any time for Q&A from
the audience
yeah and it's their first time doing the
design challenge so I imagine there
wasn't a lot we can look at so that the
two the two areas and and I might not be
your typical audience you know because I
am indie mice and we do so much with
systematic reviews I've done systematic
reviews I can't I kind of know but but I
I thought this this telling the story
was good I think one of the big
questions and it's things that
informatics people think about is
going from the raw data in the studies
in the PDFs to how you get it in and and
what it takes and what issues you eluded
at the end that you went through this
all by hand and you know there's
probably a lot of people in the
informatics people in audience saying oh
my god why do we have to do that you
know you know it's like unscrambling
eggs as we sometimes say the other thing
that other area and I'll then pass the
mic up to anyone else who has thoughts
um is I you gave a nice demo on the
features but how would people actually
use it who when the actual users be you
know would it be clinicians trying to
find the best evidence to make a
clinical decision you know would it be
other researchers um so maybe speaking
to that a little bit might be useful
because I mean usually when things are
designed they're designed with an
audience so on the topic of the the
scenario that you explored which I think
was really helpful because the tool as
you presented it seems fairly fairly
seamless and I think it might help to
have a direct comparison to how you
would answer that same question without
the tool because that's going to really
help surface the improved efficiency and
I would imagine also potentially the the
ability to not just do it quickly but do
it correctly and getting that
information so if you could just have
like one or two slides where you say
okay here's the question if we were
going to do this just with the PDF we
would start with this page and then that
page especially for the comparison you
were talking about when you would
involve looking at I would assume
several different figures and across
many different pages exactly yeah I
don't know if you should print out the
fourteen hundred page report
I don't commit physical violence I do
think that
having that express comparison will
really lend a lot of value to what you
have put together which seems really
impressive I think this is really great
as a visualization is a tool to get this
information what Bill and Nicole have
said I wondered in addition if you could
is longing well two things number one
you know looking in the future you know
how much more automated it could be
creation of this b-but but just for for
now for this you know what was the cost
in terms of you know time or man-hours
to get to this level of interaction and
you know sort of what's the you know a
couple would use case example I know
what's the cost-benefit analysis because
if this is a really great way of getting
people to use systematic review evidence
more effectively major than that
incremental cost even if it's mostly
manual right now might be justified so
having some kind of estimate of how you
know how long did it really took and how
much effort it really was and how much
effort it would take to do that
systematic review coupled with the sort
of use case demonstration of you know
here's the old clunky error-prone way to
do it there's a new way to do it might
you know sort of make that you know
design challenge sort of more compelling
the report so we actually did have we
need to actually do this from scratch
from the beginning and implement this
integrate this into a systematic review
to see how much time it would actually
take because I Connor said we had to do
this retrospectively which was a giant
pain for many years and it's very
difficult to change their processes
quickly for a lot of good reasons
actually so for the near term with this
kind of thing will likely be based on
the artifacts as they produce them in
systematic would be right now maybe not
yeah maybe you know the stuff they Bates
the PDFs on and whatnot
so these you know estimating how long it
took you but this is an upper bound of
that and then being more integrated with
the systematic reviews you know we push
that cost down over time and at some
point you know you'd get steady-state
until we have a technological innovation
or you get more automation or something
so I still think of that you know that
would be useful you know what's the
what's the cost-benefit right now and in
your
go in the future with
yeah
I think in another setting you mentioned
that you guys have done some qualitative
or sort of usability trials with
providers are you gonna bring that
forward here because I think that would
be really interesting into that clinical
scenario that I'm trying to imagine a
position how would they use and
basically boiling it down
but that was kind of that was one of the
points we learned was that we're not
entirely sure a direct provider could
use this unless they were really an
expert like a subject matter expert or
some things so then it's okay what do we
do as the next steps but so I think
that's a related point and a toot
Connor's horn the I think arc was really
they demonstrated yesterday you know one
of the ways that they want to go forward
is potentially using workbooks similar
to the limit Connor developed in tableau
so he's kind of a good deal it are the
acts I didn't yeah that makes sense I
mean in terms of you know actually I was
there was a famous picture of back to
several courses of mind of the physician
in Great Britain in like the late 1990s
had kept every guideline that had been
nailed to him for like a year and so
there's a picture it was actually
published in British Medical Journal the
stack of guidelines you know coming up
literally like this this high you know
which of course makes them essentially
useless and obviously tools like this
are helpful so okay well and you guys
are presenting on Saturday afternoon
people who are there
[Music]
and Joan when is your reason one okay
yeah yeah for saying I'm done mr.
downside so the Amy a meeting a course
have like at least two conflicts during
those times but I will do what I can
anyways thank you and good luck and
[Applause]